Robert L Bartley author of the seven fat
years and how to do it again what's this
book all about well this book is about
the seven fat years from 1983 to 1990 we
had a big economic boom in this country
and almost forgotten it by now
would you get the title well the title
comes from the book of Genesis 7 fat
years that Joseph dreamed about or the
Pharaoh dreamed about Joseph interpreted
his dream saying now we're gonna have
seven fat years followed by seven lean
years and you think that's what we're
gonna have well I hope not I hope that
we can generate a little optimism in
this society partly by remembering what
we did during the seven fat years I
think there is a danger of seven lean
years if we get into a sign of a self
realizing pessimism that's basically
what I'm warning against we've had lots
of books written in the last couple
years and a tremendous number of them
say they were great years but you're
saying they're great years and you're
you make no apologies well and we can do
it again that's the main thing is that
there's nothing predestined about seven
lean years we can go out and apply some
of the lessons we learned during the 80s
and create prosperity maybe we can do it
a little better this time I think there
were some mistakes but I don't think
that's what most of the books have been
saying most of the books have been
saying that there was a terrible time
but in fact we grew the economy by 1/3
over these years that I'm writing about
the air we just was blend [ __ ] went up by
20% we won the Cold War
not a bad record let me ask you a
question that this struck me as I read
this book
Bob Bartley is the editor of The Wall
Street Journal has access to the
editorial page that goes into over close
to 2 million homes or people in the
United States why write a book when you
could have written tickets 7 articles
that appeared day after day in The Wall
Street Journal and get the same point
well the book of course draws very
heavily on the editorials that I wrote
going clear back to the middle 1970s but
it's a different thing if you can get it
all together in one place rather than in
little snippets day by day and I hope
that it will provide a record that
people can consult if they want to
understand kind of the continuity most
of the Wall Street Journal editorial
page or view had to do with supply-side
economics Oh quite a bit we are
generally credited with inventing
supply-side economics or at least
spreading a word of it popularizing it
really starting well before Ronald
Reagan starting in the middle of 1970s
really and as I explained in the book
the terminology may be a little
misleading there none of us at the time
thought that supply-side economics was
something new on the face of the earth
we thought it was kind of standard pre
Keynesian kind of economics that applied
better to the conditions of the 1970s
and 1980s than the Keynesianism that was
being taught in the Universities at that
time when I get back to that but I want
to ask you you have a chapter called man
from Mars what's that all about well I
have this man from Mars a kind of
opening the book I call it the paradox
of the 80s and the man from Mars lands
in Kankakee and starts wandering around
and he looks at all of the parking lots
full of cars shipped all the way from
Japan and he goes into the record stores
that now have music videos by Madonna
and Malaya vanilla yet and the kids have
$100 sneakers but everybody he listens
to and all the book titles he reads says
that the nation is declining that we
have enormous problems that we have the
S&L for example and mutated into the
eggplant
that eight Kankakee Tampa and Los
Angeles and he trying to figure out
what's going on here so he has a little
handheld attaboy and starts to punch
into it to get the statistics for these
years and and finds as I said the
economy grew by 1/3
every disposable income grew by 1/5 the
whole face of the society was will be
made really in 1980 if I recall
correctly have it in the book exactly
something like 2% of the homes had VCRs
that whole industry all those record all
those video shops were all created in
the 1980s and particularly after the
boom started in 83 why are people then
so down on the green well I think that
the the biggest reason is that rapid
progress is is unsettling that I have a
chapter in that talking about the fact
that Thomas Malthus wrote about his very
deeply pessimistic economics just at the
odds outside of the Industrial
Revolution when mankind was making this
tremendous leap well these leaps of
progress caused rapid change and in
rapid change there are always people who
lose you know some the United Auto
Workers for example lost out lost a lot
of jobs because of the rising Japanese
industry in this case a lot of chief
executive officers lost jobs when their
firms were merged or taken over and they
have to go out and create new lives for
themselves and this is this is a real
problem the reaction comes then when we
want to stop all this upset and all this
tumult and all this change and there's
kind of I think a societal reaction to
to slow things down
but you find that when you try to do
that then the whole economy slows down
that I think is paradox of these these
same thing happened in the 1930s or in a
way a reaction to the 1920s
Michael 1 what is it
Oh Michael 1 is a restaurant with very
good porterhouse steaks down in the Wall
Street area a few steps from the
American Stock Exchange and we used to
hold seminars there Bob Mondello who was
a economist at at Columbia University
and art Laffer famous now by the Laffer
curve and Jude Winooski was on my staff
at The Wall Street Journal and myself
and a few other people used to gather
there for dinner and talk generally
about economics and out of this came
supply-side economics or a view of the
modern economy that I think explains
pretty well what happened as we resolved
the economic crisis of the 1970s and
started the 75 years and when did you
start having these seminars at Michael 1
I think it was probably in 74 who's
Arthur Laffer Arthur Laffer is now a
consulting economist he was a academic
economist at the University of Chicago
and at the University of Southern
California he during this period he
achieved some sort of fame with the the
Laffer curve which said that when taxes
get so high when they get too high they
start to bring in lower revenues rather
than than higher revenues so that yes
there's the the Laffer curve as you see
drawn on a napkin that's part of the
lore that it was first drawn on a napkin
at a restaurant here in Washington this
abyss restaurant is in new york or
michael one is new york but this this
one was the two continents yeah and the
folklore of the Laffer curve napkin
you've discussed in your book that there
are several opinions on where he
actually wrote this down yes what
that folklore yes that's right well Jude
when insky is reported that he drew it
for dick cheney who was done deputy
White House chief of staff in the
conversation of three of them had a to
countenance restaurant unfortunately
neither laugher nor Cheney remembers
this and this has led to some dispute
about where it was originally drawn as I
say on the book I believe when in ski
days he's he's a good journalist and
it's the kind of thing that a journalist
would remember who is jude wanniski
goodwin in ski is the fellow that worked
for me during these years he now has his
own firm called paul economics I hired
him it was actually my first hire after
I took over the editorial page of The
Wall Street Journal in 1972 he'd been a
newspaperman in Las Vegas and and Alaska
originally from Brooklyn a very
brilliant character who really got us
all together laugher and Mundel and
myself during these years and then wrote
a book about it
modestly called the way the world works
which was one of the Bible's of the
supply-side movement in the late 1970s
and he left the journal in 78 and struck
out in his own and and you know has met
a payroll ever since you say that he was
your second choice as the number one
number to hire that you wanted to make
when you became editor in 72 who was the
first the first rich George will always
then an aide to Senator Allen Colorado
no one knew him very much but I got to
know him know him when I lived in
Washington for a year and he and I was
told at lunch one day that I was going
to take over the editorial page of The
Wall Street Journal in the next morning
I was in
George's living room trying to hire him
it didn't work out probably better for
him they're not so good for meeting
maybe this is your 20th year as editor
of the editorial or The Wall Street
Journal yeah that title has changed but
I've been running the editorial page
ever since 1972 what's the title now
title is editor and vice president now
there are lots of names and I the reason
I wrote a bunch of them down because I
wanted you to talk about the impact of
people on something like this we've
talked about Jude menisci Arthur Laffer
herb Stein what role is he playing well
herb Stein named supply-side economics
he's been mostly against it throughout
his career but he named it at at one
resort at one conference talking about
the supply-side fiscal us which he said
included maybe two economists but then
most of the people in the room wanted to
enroll in what he was describing and
when in ski then dropped the fiscal us
and just kept supply-side economics so
that's what it became this is a small
thing but I think I remember you saying
that he he named it at the homestead in
Virginia's that's correct the reason I
mentioned that is that last weekend in
the New York Times front page Sunday
lead story homestead Virginia and it was
a story about trade with third world
countries and how our trade was up and
it quoted a whole bunch of American
businessmen his homestead Virginia in
these places like Michael one where a
lot of this policies developed well the
the homestead is a famous resort hotel
there in Virginia that's host to a lot
of different conferences and I presume
this I didn't happen to read that story
but I presume this is a conference that
discussed that particular issue well I
get I guess what I'm getting at is that
you know you you name a lot of people
here and you name a location where y'all
had these conversations is that the way
American policies developed I suppose it
is I'd never really thought about that
very much but I think that
that a lot of it now is being developed
in kind of informal groups and think
tanks maybe less in universities than
you actually used to be the case because
we've had this proliferation of think
tanks a very high-powered places really
starting with Brookings and including a
I and heritage and and all whole host of
others that I think really do the the
policy oriented kind of thinking these
days much more than than the
universities other names Norman Turei
you mentioned him in the Michael one
chapter
Ozzie Norman Norman Turei is an
economist in Washington ran his own
consulting firm in these years and does
again now he was under secretary of the
Treasury under Reagan and force for tax
cuts
he's a very rigorous economist and I
think that the best job of developing
the the notion that that if you change
tax rates you change incentives that you
have to look at this from the from what
is called microeconomics that is from
the individual consumer or firm and that
that your management of the macroeconomy
has to be built on firm micro economic
views before I mentioned some more names
if you could do a couple of things right
now that would impact this economy
namely oh I would cut the capital gains
tax how far be the first one well as far
as I could I mean I would not be adverse
to eliminating it if I thought that were
politically feasible I it is not if you
look across the world most places have
very minimal and some have none and in
terms of taxes on capital gains I mean
you the income was taxed when you first
earned it and then if you invested
should you be taxed again if you
invested successfully is is the issue
what do you say to those that say it
only helped the rich well I'm not too
too concerned about that I mean you can
debate who the rich are and who who it
helps but I think that my primary
interest is that it helps the people who
want to get rich that is in particular
the the entrepreneurs which I think are
absolute key to the economy these days
and you can retrace the history the
capital gains tax was cut in 1978 and
the Steiger amendment it was called
which I discuss in the book and very
shortly thereafter it was a great
profusion in the in the venture capital
industry the start of a lot of new firms
new in the 1980s just an amazing record
of firms started by college dropouts and
illegal immigrants and so on the most
notable other are the software firms in
particular Microsoft which isn't 1980
was just a couple of guys when planned a
contract now is maybe the most valuable
piece of industrial property in the
United States after only 12 years can I
interrupt to go back to the 1978
Steiger man Williams died a Republican
from Wisconsin is route dead died at age
40 of a heart attack that's right as a
was he a member of the Ways and Means
Committee yes how could a Republican get
an amendment like this passed well it's
quite an amazing thing that that that
could happen particularly since it was
passed over the very bitter opposition
of the of the Carter White House I think
the answer is the time was ripe that
people recognized that that something
was very deeply wrong with the economy
and with the the tax policies and he
managed to sell enough Democrats on his
idea that it actually passed but I think
there was a underlying change in the
national mood I mean 1978 was also the
year
of the Proposition 13 in California it
was kind of a gathering mood I think of
which the the Steiger amendment was part
what did prop 13 do in California prop
13 very severely limited the property
taxes in California it was passed by
Howard Jarvis as a initiative that is a
they petitioned it onto the ballot and
then passed it over the objections of
the state's political leaders have you
reviewed the impact of that how many
years later 14 years later or whatever I
can't say that I have in any real
careful way but of course California did
have a big boom over most of those
fourteen years and and now recently they
raised taxes again and our troubled
economy what else would you do cut the
capital gains tax number two what would
you do well I would I would try to do
what I could to make credit available to
to small businesses I think this has
been a particular problem over the last
couple of years I noticed at the journal
we had a story here the other day about
how loans to small businesses are
starting to pick up and I think that's a
very healthy kind of thing the I noticed
the the Securities Exchange Commission
also has proposals to encourage these
kind of loans by allowing banks to sell
packages of them the way they do for
mortgages I think that are very
constructive proposal in a way this is
kind of reinventing the junk bond I mean
the junk bond was a marvelous in its
early years at least a marvelous capital
raising device for for small businesses
and and provided a lot of the startup
capital for various businesses well
we're on it Michael Milken well Michael
Milken I think is a very complicated
character that will take us some years
yet to to digest and come to some kind
of
a perspective on obviously he committed
some crimes he came he he pled guilty to
crimes I I think somewhat gratuitously
that he did not need to get involved and
and some of these two girls he didn't
need to to deal with Ivan Boesky
at the same time he also did a lot of
good for a lot of rising rising
businesses to try and and you know he
really was a very creative person and in
financing for for start-up businesses I
think a lot of his problems arose when
junk bonds then became used as a
takeover device against large
corporations and this made him
exceedingly unpopular with very
influential figures in in American
business one of your colleagues although
not in the same section James Stewart
has been here as guests on book notes
and he has a best-selling book den of
thieves would you explain the difference
between where Jim Stewart works in the
Wall Street Journal and where you work
well Jim is page one editor a very
talented editor page one is part of the
news department and I'm in the opinion
department as editor of The Wall Street
Journal I run the editorials the op-ed
material the articles on the editorial
page the leisure nartz
coverage and art set up and plus the
editorial pages of our two foreign
editions and in Hongkong and Brussels
the news department is is a different
Empire much larger one but I think not
as much fun let me ask you though about
the how that works who runs the
editorials not the editorial opinion
side but the front page the overall that
part of the paper who's in charge who's
your equal
Norman Pearlstein the executive editor
and also Paul Steiger the managing
editor are the two to executives who run
the news departments both Norman and I
report you know at the same level we
will basically report to the chairman of
Dow Jones
now let's if Norman Pearlstein has
something he wants on your editorial
page and you don't want it there does it
go there no you know it's Solem comes up
in exactly that way but you know if if
Norman has something he wants on the
editorial page probably there's a reason
for it and and I'm be very unlikely to
say no I think what about the reverse of
that what if you wanted a story written
that you wanted on the front page well I
did I wouldn't ordinarily do that to do
anything about that if I had a story
that I wanted written I'd probably go
write it on my pages rather than give it
to them but you know I might make a
suggestion sometime of a story and then
they would either follow it up or not
but I wouldn't pressure them or get out
of sorts if they didn't see the story
the same way I did
but what I'm kind of getting at is on
the James Stewart book where he comes
down hard on Ivan Boesky and Mike Milken
and Denis Levine and others there's a
you know I don't heard that much talk
but some talk about how on your
editorial page you defended Mike Milken
a lot more than that and was there a
difference of opinion between you and
the James Stewart's of The Wall Street
Journal about Mike Milken oh I think so
yes how strong a difference is well I
think in a way it's it's narrowing some
if you if you read the the epilogue to
Jim's book you find that well he thinks
that insider trading ought to be defined
in other words there's no definition of
this crime that supposedly so heinous
he goes through the fact that most of
the Giuliani prosecutions were
overturned who was Giuliani Giuliani was
the New York US attorney in New York who
was bringing these insider trading cases
under the RICO law that is a
racketeering law and he got a number of
prosecution a number of one a number of
cases but then they were a long series
of them were overturned by the appellate
judges on one ground or another of
course it didn't help Milken because he
already agreed to plead guilty and the
first of the reversals happened really
shortly after he agreed to his plea one
more question on the journal if someone
reads a front-page piece or if they read
the editorial page piece are they
looking at two different philosophies
well the front page would be it
certainly could happen I wouldn't want
to suggest that the front page has only
one philosophy I mean they cover the
news and various kinds of ways but you
could certainly there certainly have
been instances in which you have
different views on the editorial page
and the and the page one or the
Washington page this basically reflects
the fact that we on the editorial page
do our own reporting and that means we
have a set of sources and the news men
report in may have a different set of
sources and really in that kind of
position you have no alternative but to
go with your own go with your own
sources so you get differences arising
and in that way I don't think that it
may be a little unseemly sometimes but I
don't think the reader suffers is he
gets the perspective again you have what
three pages the editorial page the op-ed
page and the Arts and Leisure gets right
back to the restaurant
Michael one
another name that comes up in the
context of that is Lou Lehrman and Paul
Craig Roberts hmm who was Lou Lehrman
and why does his name come in well Lou
Lehrman was a very successful executive
with the Rite Aid Corporation who then
retired after he and his colleagues had
built the corporation came in New York
set set up the lurmen Institute which
was kind of another public policy think
shop ran that for a number of years
which we'd have little seminars and in
the afternoon on both foreign policy and
economic policy then after a point Lou
ran for governor of New York lost by a
couple hundred thousand votes to Mario
Cuomo where is he today well he's back
in the think tank business today as well
as I think being a very highly
successful investor Craig Roberts was a
Capitol Hill staffer a PhD economist
worked for Kemp for a while actually
wrote the camp Roth tax cut bill or at
least was the you know if you have to
name a single author of it at the staff
level that would certainly be Craig when
when insky left I hired Craig for a year
to come up with New York and and I kind
of keep the ball rolling a column for
for us at the journal I wrote some
editorials then came back to Washington
and then was hired in to the Reagan
administration as assistant secretary of
the Treasury very powerful force for
these ideas these now again in the think
tank business here in Washington
University of Chicago
well the University of Chicago
Department of Economics has been kind of
the traditional home of classical
economists economics all through the the
Keynesian era had a number of very
distinguished professors the most
notable in our lifetime has been Milton
Friedman and Milton Friedman basically
carried the the classical economics idea
of course he's also a very skillful
advocate and with him and with that
tradition its gathered together a lot of
very you know ardent free-market types
and it's Department of Economics in to
some extent in this business school
laugher and Mandel were both there at
different stages of their careers his
how do you characterize Milton Freeman
today in your eyes as he you know is he
a guru of this of supply-side he can
economists well Milton is in kind of a
serious position in many ways he is he
would agree with us about nine out of
ten things would we I have a little
section in there quoting some Bank
economists saying I used to be a
monetarist I think that and says I used
to be a monetarist but I've kind of come
to the conclusion that the this kind of
money supply isn't kind of the be-all
and end-all of economics the second
thing that Milton would disagree with
myself and my friends about is if he's
still an ardent proponent of floating
exchange rates that's something I think
we'd be better off to get rid of if we
got back to something like the Bretton
Woods International
monetary system those things we disagree
about we would agree that government
spending is the kind of best measure of
the government's impact on the economy
rather than for example the deficit we
would agree that it's much better to let
the markets work that it's not too good
an idea for the for the federal
government to try and you know fine-tune
the economy to jiggle it around this way
and that those very important things we
he would be a guru or a sympathizer of
this group but he has his own particular
philosophy that he has his own personal
stamp on that is a little different from
where we are let me go back to some
number of things you said and maybe
quick definitions would help us what is
a monetarist well monitors basically is
a follower of milton friedman but for us
they emphasize the very importance of
what we call the money supply like which
is M 1 M 2 etc which is under the
control more or less of the Federal
Reserve System in other words the the
Federal Reserve can can control at least
bank reserves and then those bank
reserves kind of are loaned out and
become M 1 or M 2 what are you talking
about when you say Bretton Woods
well Bretton Woods as a Resort Hotel in
New Hampshire where in 1944 and
the Allied powers negotiated a an
international monetary arrangement that
is they said okay when the war is over
we're going to have to get the world
economy straightened out and they came
up with some arrangements on exchange
rates they created the World Bank and
the International Monetary Fund at the
same time they're not at Bretton Woods I
don't think but in conjunction with that
you had the general agreement on tariffs
and trade to cut tariffs around the
world and this GATT that's got yeah in
this arrangement with opening of the
world markets and stable exchange rates
basically pegged to the dollar which
then had a relationship to gold led to
an amazing time and look in the world
economy there was really a golden era
between all about 1950 when all these
arrangements were in place and and 1973
you can see things kind of break in 73
and that period from fifty to seventy
three is was really the greatest growth
period of the century both in the
industrial economies and in the
developing economies by the way pegging
off your book the seven fat years seven
83 to 90 yes how do these years how
important are these years in history
well they're awfully important in
history in terms of the geopolitics I
mean this is when the Cold War was over
and I think that that if we handle
things right now we may be entering an
entirely new era and we've had a pretty
ghastly century
with two world wars and the Great
Depression and people and then followed
by the Cold War and I hope that that the
breaching of the Berlin Wall in 1989 may
assure an an entirely new and much more
hopeful era we also have we also have
enormous technological progress going on
at the moment I call it the Second
Industrial Revolution we've had atomic
energy we've had the splitting of the
gene we've had probably most important
the invention of the transistor and now
the microchip it's changing the entire
texture of the economy from an
industrial economy and doing the
information economy this should be very
good for us and between the between the
Second Industrial Revolution on the end
of this world war confrontation should
allow us if we kind of get things right
- to construct a much more hopeful era
than we have grown up there back to
Michael one how often did you have
dinner they're all I don't know that I
could count the times maybe maybe it
doesn't I don't know
sold I mean you didn't go there every
week oh no no there wasn't any any
regular schedule to it and but of course
the in a way Michael one is is a symbol
even if we weren't at Michael one these
discussions over about these ideas were
almost constant they would be around my
desk at the at the journal they would be
by phone with with laugher and Mundel
and later with with Turay and Robertson
Washington so that there was an awful
lot of intellectual ferment I wouldn't
want to create the idea it only happened
at my
well I just mentioned that because that
you mean you defer to it but I wanted
wanted to find out what happened as
Michael one is a symbol what happened
with the information that you all
developed would you do with it well a
lot of it of course we published in The
Wall Street Journal editorial Zoar op-ed
pieces well I think probably more up ed
pieces than than editorials although we
had had editorials - under whose name
under really a great variety of people's
names I mean when insky wrote some
notable ones but what we found was that
once we started to run some of these
ideas authors who shared them and have
started coming out of the woodwork and
we'd get the submissions from people in
Atlanta or San Francisco that that fit
as part of the framework and we would
run those and I think that's one reason
I think that the you know this is not
something that we dreamed up all by
ourselves it was part of the temper of
the time and the idea is there were a
lot of people were kind of thinking
along the same lines and once an outlet
for these ideas was created it became a
kind of self generating process are you
still in touch with all those people yes
indeed there's one name I haven't
mentioned that kept coming up throughout
the book and that's Jack Kemp
what role does he play and is he your
candidate for president well I think
he'd make a good one
uh you know it's I mean we got enough
candidates for president this year I
guess but at some point in his career
I'd certainly would I would look
enthusiastically on that he might not be
the only candidate that I would be
willing to back enthusiastically but
Jack of course was was instrumental in
in the political side of this he's that
fellow picked up on these ideas who was
the driving force behind the Kemp Roth
bill that then ultimately became the
Ragan 1981 tax cuts and he's still at it
today you said something earlier I
wanted you to find also that rather than
looking at the deficit people all look
at the percentage of government expense
as it relates to the GNP yes that's why
I think that well I think that's the
best single measure what's GNP GNP is is
the total output of the economy I guess
these days now we've switched to gross
domestic product and what is that well
you give us a finger on roughly what
that is is it five trillion yeah
something in that neighborhood I I'm not
real good at remembering specific
figures
so if we have 1.2 trillion in government
expenditures that's what 20% of the GDP
well the governor government
expenditures are now running around 24
25 percent of GNP had a chart in the
book expenditure tax receipts are
running around 19 maybe 20 percent the
interesting thing about this chart is
that the receipts are really pretty
stable going back clear to 1950 they're
20% 21% might be a record-low might be
17% or it's a very narrow band the
expenditure is on the other hand took
off and starting really in 1974 and the
difference of course is is the deficit
how high is that percentage of GNP the
expenditure part expenditure part about
25 that's federal they were then state
and local spending would be in addition
well when do you get nervous well I get
nervous at 25 for everything or just the
feds know for the for the Fed I think so
you're comfortable at 24 well I would
like to I would like to see it well
I think it's the trend more than
anything else that's disturbing I mean
the trend is more each year and as you
take more each year it means you're
taking a larger and larger share of the
new money in the economy and at some
point that becomes a disincentive to to
production disincentive in the private
sector and and the general economy
starts to slow down I think that that's
a much the the the rationale for looking
at expenses rather than at the deficit
is that the expenses are the amount of
money that the government is taking out
of the private sector now whether it
takes those by taxes or by borrowing
them is kind of a secondary matter that
the primary matter is how much money is
it taking that's measured by
expenditures we take your temperature on
three men George Bush on one at a time
okay George Bush I would have been
happier if Bush had been a little more
Reagan asked a little more like Ronald
Reagan I think ultimately however the
records still out the revocation of his
no new taxes pledge I think hurt him
both politically and economically
I think the 1990 budget deal raising
taxes once you're already in a recession
is a very bad mistake on the other hand
I'm not sure how much choice he had at
that time because it also came just as
he was building support for his war in
Iraq which I support so he may not have
been in a position to have a
confrontation or with Congress over the
budget just at that time so you think
you can forgive him
that a little bit I think if he has a
second term you're likely to have a
different Congress and he might be more
successful because of that will he be
back
I suspect so Bill Clinton and I don't
have any real strong opinions about Bill
Clinton I don't think you know he he's a
menace I'm not sure that he really
believes in anything though he's just
such a his whole life has been as a
politician that you know he's so that if
he takes a position the kind of starting
assumption is that well he's taking that
for some political reason not because he
actually believes in it
Ross Perot well Ross Perot I don't know
what he believes and either he hasn't he
keeps I knows he's gonna do these
wonderful things as president but he
doesn't he doesn't tell us what they are
I think unless he can get that
straightened out his candidacy may be in
some difficulty there's a journal ever
endorsed the journal I think so far as I
know the journal has has endorsed one
presidential candidate and it's 100 and
some year history that was Herbert
Hoover and I think maybe we learned our
lesson and so we don't formally endorse
now we we are pretty outspoken in our
editorials and you will won't where we
stand in any particular election a
sometimes we may have stronger opinions
and others but you will find that you
know if you read us you you will find
what we think about the men and the
issue is but we don't typically write
editorials saying well we endorse
so-and-so and because we endorse them
you should vote
that's a little bit of an empty exercise
how many people work for you on the
editorial board well my budget staff is
I think 35 people at the moment this
includes the people abroad includes the
leisure and arts people that includes
the clerical people so that if you ask
how many people are actually
contributing editorials the kind of the
question becomes where do you draw the
line we don't have too many people who
do that full time we have people like
Paul Gigot and Washington and Tim
Ferguson and Los Angeles and George
Malone and Brussels who write columns
and write one column a week plus they
write editorials the principal force
behind the editorials putting them
together every day now is my is the
deputy editor at the editorial page
Daniel hunting her and then we have a
couple of other people who write
editorials full-time and then we have a
variety of people including some of the
leisure and arts people who contribute
one now and then how often do you
actually sit down and write a full
editorial personally all probably in
this last little while every other week
or so I have also been written some
byline columns here recently though and
what do you most likely to feel the
strongest about well I I have been
writing some economic editorials here
because that's what we have needed I
also wrote about the Los Angeles Riots
in one of our two long editorials on
that I am sure that is the presidential
campaign heats up I'll have some
editorials about politics I have a way
of picking off the rapists topics on it
and they're the ones that usually get me
moving yeah for a moment let's suggest
that there's a 20 year old out there
watching who's always wanted to write
for the wall
Street Journal what's the best possible
training to work for you at The Wall
Street Journal
well the best possible training for
writing is writing
that's what Hemingway said the way you
write is to apply the seat of your pants
to the seat of the chair and write and
the way you the way you become
journalists is to get something
published whether it's in a campus
publication or whatever and that is when
we sit on to hire someone and you're in
the infrequent occasions in which we
actually have openings what counts are
the clips other words what they
published elsewhere that they can send
along with their letter that's by far
the overwhelming factor in hiring
decisions in the last 20 years how often
have you had an opening well had that's
kind of a specific fact well I mean just
well we are likely to have an opening of
a professional level every other year
something on that neighborhood that
would include editors as well as writers
your background hometown and university
and suddenly to study well I was born in
Marshall Minnesota grew up basically in
Ames Iowa went to Iowa State University
there worked for a year at the Grinnell
Iowa Herald Register which comes out
twice a week yeah opportunity while I
was there to hone my skills of the
photographer as well as as well as a
writer I took a master's degree in
political science at the University of
Wisconsin my undergraduate major at Iowa
State had been in journalism and I was
hired on to the Chicago beer over The
Wall Street Journal in 1962 as a report
has a reporter and I was two years as a
reporter and 64 I came on to the
editorial page in New York is this book
number one for you or have you written
others oh yes no no no this is this is
the first book that I've written to my
father and the memory of my mother they
arranged their lives so that I might
do this how long do you think that out
that's your dedication yeah well I
didn't take very long I think how did
they arrange their lives to help you
they made sure I got a good education
and they went to some effort I think to
do that your father alive your mother
dead yes that's right where does my
father still an isle what did he do for
a living yeah he was a veterinarian and
while they was names a professor of
veterinary medicine at the University
there and how did they influence in
those early years well there I guess
made me a serious young man the
traditional discipline and support and
they encouraged me to you know they got
me to into the Ames public schools which
were and I have every reason to believe
still are quite remarkable schools
because it's a university town and and
most of the children great percentage of
the children have from faculty families
and really a very very intellectual kind
of place and at the same time a kind of
down-to-earth Midwestern kind of place
and marvelous education home of Iowa
State yes that's right the engineering
and agriculture college here in the book
you mentioned a couple of other people
that an economist by the name of say you
know Bob T say yes who was he well he
was a very notable classical economist I
don't know why right now that you know
from a couple centuries ago or a century
ago he was after Adam Smith but 1767 to
1835 I thought you might have it there
but he he formed what's called sales law
which was kind of the bedrock
proposition of classical economics and
says-- law is that
production creates its own demand in
other words that the economy is a
cyclical kind of process that if you
produce something you pay money as I
explained it in there there you know
widget makers pay the their employees to
make the widgets and the employees use
their compensation to buy widgets and
and if you extend this over an economy
and over a great number of great variety
of goods you have a picture of an
economy when were you first introduced
to him not in person but I mean well I
remember art Laffer saying during these
discussions I didn't know whether it was
at Michael 1 or whether it was in my
office but he's saying that you know you
got to learn about say you learn about
sales law it's this is what I believe in
it's what you believe in - of course
then I didn't know what it was there's
another name I'm sure I'll mispronounce
it haic Hayek yeah Hayek who is he well
he is a very famous Austrian economist
who died here this year is a very
elderly man he was a contemporary and a
critic of Keynes and then he was more or
less forgotten for a great many years
until well he was more or less forgotten
is not quite correct because he wrote a
very famous book called the road for
road to serfdom
but he wasn't viewed as in the forefront
of modern economics during the Keynesian
era and but I think that keynesian ism
kind of collapsed during the 1970s when
you had this simultaneous inflation and
and unemployment that the Keynesian
formulation doesn't even allow I can't
explain it
well and this perception I think
gradually spread around the world and lo
and behold very lateness life then Hayek
was given a Nobel Prize for economics
and we better define who John Maynard
Keynes's was well John Maynard Keynes
was the the most influential economist
of this century British wrote during
before enduring the depression and Great
Britain his most famous book is called
the the general theory and it really
established a view of economics for two
generations it published in the 30s and
it was really dominant until till the
70s and all structures of economical
structures of thought were built around
Keynes general theory I and most of the
people of Michael 1 are admirers of
Keynes as a person but we think his and
his theories may have been relevant and
needed during the Great Depression but
they didn't apply very well to the 1970s
there is in the book our Veloz quote
from Hayek who said that toward the end
of Keynes life he was very worried that
his theories might be misused as
particularly as an Indian for inflation
but he told Hayek that well don't worry
about it because if that ever starts to
get out of hand I can turn it around
overnight
two weeks later Keynes was dead couldn't
turn it around and I actually know what
have to will have to be explained by
history is how a whole generation of
economists kind of woke up bewildered
because they couldn't understand things
that
had been fairly widely understood before
the Keynesian revolution knowing what
you know and think about every day do
you often it's a leading question but do
you ever sit and watch the political
discussion and listen to people out in
the country talk back and say if they
really knew what they were talking about
they'd never say that well you have
occasions of that of course but you know
I'm kind of a populist I believe that
that the common people out there in the
country are really pretty smart they may
not be able to tell you about Keynes and
Hayek and all that but they they have a
kind of a street sense of what's working
and what isn't out it out in the street
and I think that when you get something
like the kind of change in the mood that
I was talking about in 1978 that often
the common people in the street are
ahead of the policy makers and the big
thinkers this is what the book looks
like it's by Robert L Bartley the editor
of The Wall Street Journal it's called
the seven fat years and how to do it
again thank you for joining us thank you
very much Brian